you know we're currently in the middle
of the the corona
crisis and uh you know that's one
industry that cannot work with
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders
hi my pleasure it is so great to have
you here from mit to mckinsey to
a chief digital officer of bangkok and
now
a running innovation in digital for el
al did i get that right
almost almost what did i miss today i'm
the
today i'm the chief digital and
information officer for laos so i run
rit so all the technology related to it
as well as the digital
uh business line um i also sit on a
house uh
on the board of al's innovation arm
which is called cockpit
wow which is uh an innovation home okay
so i'm already very
upset that we only have 19 minutes left
so i want to just dive straight in there
what does it mean to run innovation for
a company that is
so large you know air travel industry
airline let alone banks it's an old
industry we've seen it for so long
what's happening today and what what is
your role in there
oh that's that's a huge question yeah i
can talk about four hours
um so let's let's let's
let's try to uh to break it down a
little bit great
um
you know first thing about innovation is
trying to define
uh what is innovation and how you think
about it in the context of a big
organization
um you know when i think about when i
think about organization
innovation in an organization you could
think about it in a
in a in a few uh in a few ways right
there's something uh like
incremental innovation which is
important it's a day-to-day life for
pushing your
uh product your digital product your
customer journeys
one step further thinking about what
your customers need and addressing that
the second step is you know we may call
it a disruptive innovation like what are
the next big
moves the next big move that you're
gonna do
to disrupt the market change the game
change the rules
uh get ahead of your competition sure
and then uh the third layer of
innovation is more uh
you know maybe you could call it
emerging or exponential
uh innovation it's kind of the things
that are
further on the horizon uh you say okay
they may have impact on my business uh
uh in a few years may or may not and i
want to play
um and and i wanna
and maybe at least play with them or
experiment with them just to be ready
uh when those uh windows arrive
which one are you most excited about of
those three
you know as a leader of a business of
digital technology you have to do
all three uh but the question is kind of
your portfolio right where where do you
focus
uh yeah you know is it uh most of your
focus needs to
need to be when you're running an
organization you're running on another
startup
you have a current customer you have
your current business you have your pnl
you need to pay the bills
you know you're selling a product that
works for customers so most of the focus
most of the time what you would call
incremental innovation
so you know continuously improving your
products and services and
and and so and so forth uh what but
whether that's
70 of your focus or 90
of your focus that depends on the
organization on your resources and so on
so forth
and just to put that you know to give
more concrete examples so for example
when
um as chief digital uh officer in bank
of poly
uh you know incremental innovation was
about launching a new mobile app
for our uh concern for our customers and
our business customers
this disruptive innovation was uh
launching beat which is today the
biggest and most successful
yes ptp payment up in israel so that
completely disrupted the payment
networks
but uh another example of disruptive
innovation would be um
we launched a platform for small
businesses to help them
accelerate their their transformation
into a digital business so for example
you can create
an e-commerce website within a few
clicks
and as a bank we served it to our
customer uh well
uh so that would be disruptive
innovation uh well you know exponential
innovation or you know experimental
would be things like blockchain which we
played with uh
you know things like uh vr trying to
think about
how a new interaction model in a digital
way will play
uh for a potential future future
customer right they will not have an
impact today they will not have anything
but tomorrow
but they're probably going to have an
impact in a in the next few
next few years so it sounds to me the
context of an airline is slightly
different
right so it sounds to me that that
incremental
incremental innovation and the way
you're describing it is is how you're
adapting to the changing market and
you've seen
you you're seeing some other players
that are making these incremental
changes and they're going
well for them so there's you know the
milestones that you're trying to reach
and the growth that you're going to see
is pretty evident from the get-go
whereas disruptive innovation is sort of
this like
innate startup feeling where you're
saying we have this good hypothesis
we think this is going to really change
consumer behavior and going to really
change the way people interact with our
product and that is sort of what you did
with bit with bit
what is that like in the airline
industry right now
in the online industry it's slightly
slightly different um
you know the basic airline product and
service is uh
physical yeah uh the physical seat that
you see
you know we're currently in the middle
of the the corona
crisis and uh you know that's one
industry that cannot work with zoom
and yeah you know we're dealing we're
dealing with that crisis but the fact is
it's a physical product about moving
people from point a to point b
and giving them the service and um
and all the wrapping around it where
technology you know is an enabler
technology drives the
you know it it will have plays a
significant role
in your purchasing journey in the
decision during purchasing journey it
plays a significant role
in your overall experience but at the
end of the day it's not the
the core uh the core product uh
therefore a lot of the focus is actually
more focused on
the you know incremental innovation
right
around a
around improving the experience of the
customer
by creating a better mobile app
that manages for example the the way
they think about their journey from home
to the airport
reduces the friction reduces the pain
allow them to do more things
um more disruptive innovations i think
that
uh you know we experiment with to do
with our launch to support so for
example
uh one potential disruption is going
beyond just the pure
airline operation operator um
that moves customers from point a to
point b and looking at the entire travel
experience so
we launched an experiment
and ran it for a few months which we
called it taxi pool and the idea was
um you know when we interviewed
customers
we learned that one of the main pain
points was actually the cost of
uh you know you may you the cost of
traveling
from the airport to their hotel because
the taxes can be very expensive in some
some of the cities so we launched a
pilot around or experiment around an app
that connects people on the same plane
that are all driving to the same hotel
uh
and you know bring them together to the
same taxi uh
and that was quite successful and we too
you know we stopped it and we talked
about how to integrate create a better
engineering so that's an example of a
more
disruptive innovation another example of
destructive innovation is changing the
way you think about flights
so right thinking about you know
searching flights and destinations
and in instead of uh
uh instead of uh you know okay i know i
want to go to new york in these and
these dates
actually say okay what are you looking
for what type of vacation you're looking
for
you know what are your budgets you know
what kind of cities you're thinking
about
so it's you know it's it's kind of
disrupting the customer decision journey
about around
where to where to fly of course uh so
it goes to finland there are things kind
of in between you know there's a bit of
a gradient like a bidding platform we
launched with a startup called b2fly
or big flyer sorry where you know
customers can can name their own price
for the flight uh
like a reverse speed yeah um so again
you know we're not we're not disrupting
the entire industry like in the banking
payment space because they're not
but we're disrupting or significantly
changing the landscape of a
few elements uh in the um in the
customer journey
and again obviously the big disruption
is going to happen now unfortunately uh
and ali is working with that crisis
right
is the changes we're going to have
around the travel journey
given the coronavirus requirements so
shahar very quickly how many
how many people work for ll um
let's say as of january of this year
of this past january uh again
numbers are very different these days no
i know i know i'm alluding to a bigger
question
it's around six it's a little bit more
than six thousand people and and how
about bank appointment
bank appointment is uh ten thousand
people again
okay so you know when you ask i'm i'm
now in palo alto
and i'm also a part of a of a visa of an
early stage vc fund called j ventures
and every startup we meet and every
startup around me
is saying we're disruptive we're
innovative we're changing the way people
do xyz
and you know it's one thing to take a
team of five people
and to to have faith in the idea that
they'll be able to you know execute
quickly
and be very creative and no strings
attached to their current product
now i have the privilege of talking to
somebody who's trying to lead
a similar mindset but in a but in
companies that have
thousands of people thousands of you
know hierarchies and management
and boards and and history
so overall over your experience from
mckinsey to now
what are some of these companies are
considered small when you look globally
i also
yeah of course yeah when i was a partner
mckinsey for example helped lead the
technology the digital transformation in
lloyd's banking group in the uk
that's a hundred thousand people wow
organizations so that's a completely
different scale
um but the challenges are very similar
um
i think the the dirty secret around
innovation
is when people say innovation especially
in big organizations
they always think about you know what
what what's the big idea let's think
about ideas let's brainstorm ideas let's
you know bring these uh consultants or
recession but
but the dirty secret is that actually
innovation is all about execution
uh you know the ideas are out there even
for startups
that go to uh vc unless you have a very
kind of deep tech kind of startups photo
startup will have an idea that's been tr
in fact the vc would like to see that
someone else has done the
same idea or something similar uh you
know
the famous case about uh facebook and
you know
the myspace or friendster example or
lyft and uber
oh yeah there are tons of examples right
um sure
and in a big organization it's it's it's
it's
even probably even more important around
execution a bigger organization
execution is a lot around
uh you know changing the the
organization changing the way you work
changing the way you think making things
happen
um versus
you know for example startup where you
need to build the product and get it to
market
um so for example in beat a lot of the
challenges
on in in execution or around convincing
the the bank that this
this is uh something you need um
and then you know getting the the
regulator
getting a regulatory approved getting
the legal approve actually building the
product
uh was you know not a big deal because i
had a big yeah i had a big factory
you know it's a bank of all in my tea
that knows how to build product there
was a challenge we wanted we needed to
build a product very very fast
so we brought a lot of innovation around
the way we work and becoming more agile
and using new tools
and so on and so forth so there's a lot
of innovation in the way of working
which allowed us to launch a product
very fast no it's it's fascinating so
now we we can't
like you mentioned before our call you
can't disconnect from the times that
we're living in and
uh you're leading innovation and a
disruption in
in the travel industry right now which
unfortunately is probably getting the
hardest hit
out of any industry in the world
basically coming to a halt
and who knows when it will be again when
people feel comfortable
getting on planes and going away so what
what is what
give me just a little bit of a
high-level landscape of what's happening
in the travel
industry now and perhaps what are some
of the challenges that you're thinking
about
that are most important
uh you know everybody sees the the
challenges imagine you're
you you know you're a company and within
one month
you stop selling your products uh
you know from 100 to zero uh and at the
same time all the products you sold six
months ago people come in and ask
for uh to return them and get the refund
there's a reason why all the airlines in
the world are struggling
and need support and looking forward
you know with challenging times the the
challenging circumstances
there's still a lot of innovation a lot
of innovation for example in and out
comes in the business side and the
commercial side
so it doesn't have innovation doesn't
have to be always a technology driven or
digital driven
so for example taking a passenger's plan
passenger plane
and quickly converting them into uh
cargo planes yes yeah
yeah and coming with innovative deal
with the government or with other
government to bring in medical supplies
so one of the airlines that's very
quickly changed all the airplanes and
pushed uh and pushed to um
to excel to increase their cargo
activities not only to israel
we also delivered medical supplies to
the us we're delivering medical supplies
to
italy so you know it required a lot of
innovation i cannot take credit for it
but an example of you know business
commercial operational innovation that
you need
and flexibility that you need to have in
times of crisis
no that makes a lot of sense so you know
we're
i can't believe we're almost getting to
the 20 minutes and it's very upsetting
to me
but you know i'm looking at myself now
and i'm on this group
path of growth where i want to be in a
position where i feel like i'm i'm able
to harness innovation and i'm able to
push it forward
and assess which elements of a company
will be disruptive and will be effective
so maybe you can give me some of your
earned secrets if you will about how you
approach different ideas and different
problems
and how do you really try and assess
what's viable
and what's just you know white noise
that that excited people are talking
about
um well you know the the method of
lean startup and get things done and
test a good customer
uh you know put it in front of customer
and see what works
is always a good thing yeah
for a big organization uh what you want
to do
is you know you could also look just
look outside
they being a follower
is much more important than being on the
again depending on your business if
you're an r d business or big classical
traditional organization
you want to be a fast follower you want
to see things that work outside say okay
i see the work i said somebody put the
effort
um somebody put the effort and
i see that it's working in other markets
other geographies likely
let's okay we have validation for that
then let's build it and move
and and move forward so uh
you know those just two two uh
two of the tools that i'm using uh that
i'm using
on the day today you know either someone
else done it or can i get validation
from similar things that this thing is
going to work or okay let's put it in
front of your customer
test it iterate it over time again the
challenge for big organizations around
execution and making it happen
so taking a big organization that work
in kind of what's called waterfall
methodology where you build big projects
it takes you a lot of time to put them a
lot of time to to to get the big budget
changing the organization debt into okay
let's start small and then grow
creates a lot of challenges for a big
organization starting from
[Music]
you know how you're going to budget for
something like that because in a big
organization you need to have
a certainty of budget tell me how much
this project is going to cost well i
don't know necessarily because i need to
test it first
etc it creates challenges around
allocation of internal resources it
creates challenges around
you know marketing tells me okay tell me
when it goes to market so i can launch a
marketing
thing well it depends on you know the
feedback that are going to get
so a lot of the challenge of making
innovation happening in a big
organization
is dealing with the execution and and
driving the change in the ways of
working within the organization
now that that makes a lot of sense and
you know
i don't get to meet that many people
that that both had uh
had a very active role in a consultancy
out of mit and then went on to running
innovation and disruption for
for for companies like fintech and
travel do you feel that this experience
at mckenzie was something that was
beneficial to you that
that gave you sort of skill sets that
would be very hard to accumulate
otherwise to get to the positions you're
at now
absolutely uh i don't think that anyone
else would give you a different answer
when you ask them about their career
no you know because consultancy
especially today is not
an idea is not a a very um you know i'm
looking at all my
friends at stanford and my colleagues
thinking about consultancy i think
they're thinking about it differently
than it was
maybe 10 years ago people are very quick
to just jump straight to a startup or
straight to big companies
and and skip sort of that path
well listen mckenzie's amazing
experience i agree with you the word
consulting is a confusing word
because it implies you know you come to
someone you give them some
uh some ideas a little bit of advice and
then you go that's not the way
all big consultants work and especially
mckinsey
you know to be successful time every
time over time in the best companies in
the world once which are the
big consultants company you need to
deliver impact you cannot deliver
impact you know by just giving some
generation some random advice right
deliver impact by making things happen
sure everywhere whether it's a startup
or an organization so as a consultant
and you know you get to do a lot of
hands work and a lot of actual delivery
right and again depends on which area
you go it's a it's a big world and there
are different things from strategy to
implementation
in my career a lot of my focus was
actually on the implementation side of
consol
consulting so i i helped companies drive
digital transformation
not by giving them a blueprint and then
going away but actually giving them a
blueprint then being part of the team
uh that the believers that helping them
build the team helping them change the
methods
right then taking the product to market
and doing the iteration and being there
for them
uh and throughout the entire process and
sometimes
you know or actually many times getting
my hand dirty in the actual
implementation
of the thing and all the consultants by
the way these days they had programmers
we had designers that we brought
uh you know data scientists so actually
doing the work and the implementation
very significantly blurred since
uh you know uh 20 30 years ago
yeah definitely so right before we leave
i have to ask you my last question which
is also my favorite
i'd like to know three words that you
would best describe yourself as
or perhaps that people who work with you
would describe you as
um so uh i think
uh the first word is uh
impact because i keep driving people to
okay what
what what does it mean what it's going
to do for the customer what it's going
to do for the business
right all my uh um
all the people that work with me know
that you know this is where i'm driving
uh the second
uh the second word uh
probably creativity uh makes sense
because i keep
challenging my teams to think about a
creative solution and creative a
way to solve a problem um
and the third one
it's a tough question um it's the
hardest question maybe uh you know
yeah maybe play maybe playfulness i love
i hear that a lot i love it
yeah yeah yeah so you know not
everything has to be
super serious you know it has to be it
has to be fun
right uh organization is serious
business we deal with serious things
again
corona crisis and we did it but you know
the day-to-day interactions
with the team when we think of a problem
when we think about you know you need to
be
bring like the positive energy and and
the spirit to think about okay
100 percent enjoy what we're doing
definitely
thank you so so much for the time good
luck with everything that's happening
now
and and i hope that that both alal and
all the other airlines will be able to
to come out the other side
uh stronger but it is very difficult and
i really appreciate you taking the time
for this
absolutely my pleasure thank you thank
you
hey